we're going to make some brownies and
probably going to eat they're going to
have hot dogs in them no they won't
courney is a chef she's also one of my
best friends and she's written so many
cookbooks worked in incredible famous
kitchens we're so lucky to have her on
the show Making Elizabeth's food let's
begin shall
we one of the things that I love about
your T specifically is that you found a
way to take things that are like
memories of my childhood things that I
love as a kid but then you elevate it
and make into something where I feel
like it's cool that I'm an adult like
it's an adult
version yeah the adult version of the
things I really want cuz I had it as a
kid speaking of which okay so I'm about
to make peanut butter chocolate brownies
with shushu and Alice these are the
brownies that kind of brought them
together in the show they play a very
large role in the show that's right it's
something that Elizabeth makes for mad
for her lunch I'm really interested to
see how they're going to do I think
they're going to be really great Bakers
I can't wait to find out what's going to
happen first before we even get started
I would love to hear just a little bit
about your characters on the show so um
I'm mad zot and I'm the daughter of the
main character in the show what do you
need I'll get the flower you go to the
butcher counter copy but nothing to lean
oh of course and what about you shushu
I'm a Anda Pine and I am her best friend
in the show correct yes and in real life
yes and in real life yes why do we know
that that's
amazing
Amanda mom can Amanda come over today
all right let's start let's start with
the ree okay so the chocolate peanut
butter brownies have two parts we're
going to make the chocolate part first
and then we're going to go make the
peanut butter part okay Alice do you
want to be the official stirer for this
one okay whisk that together all right
now you keep stirring and I'm going to
I'm going to pour in the butter so this
is melted butter it goes just like that
that smells so good yeah it going to
taste so good oh it's getting bunched up
yeah so if you want to switch to this
you can it's a little bit thick you're
going to have to put some put some
muscle into it I'm going to get some
muscle in here get some MUSC all right
Cho Chu are you ready yes we're going to
crack the eggs into it while Alice stirs
have you ever cracked an egg before yes
you're an old Pro look at that all right
so you're going to add the eggs in new
go eggs yeah my God you keep stirring
don't stop stirring this is an important
very important part keep mix it it's
getting really gooey here can I show you
a little trick yeah sometimes this is
called folding if you like scrape like
this and you can just and you can really
and then you can just like get vigorous
vigorously stir okay vigorous yeah yeah
get
vigorous it's time to add the flower
shushu would you like to do the honors
just don't dump it in all at once kind
of sprinkled in a little bit of the time
perfect keep mixing yeah keep mixing so
do you all like gooey brownies or do you
like cakey brownies do you have a
preference I like both really both yeah
well I like a warm gooey brownie yeah me
too I'm a gooey person myself all right
that means that we all like gooey yeah
we all like we all like gooey that means
you put less flour in because the more
flour you add to the brownie batter the
more cake like it'll be so this recipe
is very gooey cuz it hardly has any
flour in it that looks great aming let's
set this aside now that the chocolate
batter is finished let's move on to the
peanut butter sound good peanut butter
which do you'all like better chocolate
or peanut butter chocolate all right so
you stir and you're going to add the
powdered sugar just like that what do
you think makes like what do you think
makes best friends best friends like
what is it about I think that you've got
to be friendly kind you've got to be
loyal and you have to stand up for each
other yeah and be supportive yeah you
know what I forgot something I forgot
the butter I'm going to pour the butter
in okay okay pour in the butter good you
know what else friends can make mistakes
but they can still support each other
like forgetting the butter we're still
going to make
work perfect we have oh that's fluffy
both of our batters made now we're going
to spread it into got to get excess the
dis how are youall feeling how are you
feeling about everything so far peanut
butter you feel you feel peanut butter
making my mou water it's making my mouth
water okay so I'm going to put half of
the batter in and you're going to spread
it out okay and it doesn't have to be
perfect cuz when it b as it bakes in the
oven it'll make the chocolate and the
butter spread out okay all right it's
peanut butter time just like a half a
scoop yeah and then just scoop it down
just like that and let's plan it let's
do like I one here one here one here one
here and one
here we're going to put more chocolate
on top and then we're going to swirl
let's
swirl swirl swirl look at all these
swirl oh my God you're doing such a good
job thank you this looks perfect I'm
going to go ahead and put these in the
oven okay and we will eat all of the
batter oh
[Music]
yeah
so while the brownies are baking what's
your what's your like go-to breakfast
Crepes Crepes what's your what's your
go-to breakfast um pancakes and and hash
browns those are really good just like
classic American breakfast yeah I'm on
board with that beated hydroxy
talline A good rule of thumb is not to
eat foods that share ingredients with
jet fuel
I'll add it to my vocabulist I smell the
brownies do y'all smell them I smell
them I think they're finished
T oh my God so
good now this is a little trick too this
is a professional trick we we made these
so they would be like little lifters so
it'll be really easy just go
plop plop and there you go so now it's
really easy to just cut
and eat that looks great okay here we go
I don't believe in plates yeah who needs
plates who needs them here has plates we
don't need you all right all right here
we go let's see if this is any good
let's see how do we do oh my gosh
they're so gooey you can tell there
wasn't a ton of flower gooey they're so
good I should get paid and brownie I
think that can be arranged thank you all
so much for joining me in the kitchen
today I had so much fun
and you can see more of these characters
and recipes in lessons in chemistry on
Apple TV Plus thank
[Music]
you